welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar advanced liver
tissue model for improved in vitro
prediction presented by Matthew Shipton
chief operating officer Hugh rel
corporation my name is Xavier guitars
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop one box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Matthew Shipton I
will now turn the presentation over to
him Thank You Xavier and thank you to
the folks at Labrador giving me the
opportunity to present on more advanced
liver tissue model systems to improve in
vitro prediction topics I will be
covering as a brief overview
various advanced liver model systems
I'll give an in-depth review of the hero
system where I am currently chief
operating officer and talk about our
functional liver model I also talk about
some of the next-generation micro
fluidics I'm sure many are familiar with
the organ on chip systems that are
widely popular and becoming more and
more popular there are three of very
well-known advanced tissue systems that
are out there for in vitro liver
prediction the hero system which is a
self-assembling co-culture system by
reclamation IV TS have had a pack
which is a micro pattern system as well
as in Sphero
and their miniaturized steroids that can
form miniaturized tissue models a number
of companies are also using the
commercially available ultra low
attachment plates and primary hepatocyte
to create their own spheroids as I said
our hero system is a self-assembling
co-culture comprised of primary human
hepatocytes co cultured with non
parenchymal stromal cells here you can
see a differences with the system in the
URL human the hero primate here l dog
and Ural rats the thing about our L
system is along with the spheroids is
they're amenable to a variety of
different plate formats and culture
techniques unlike some of the micro
pattern system that's currently on the
market here you can see a nice example
of our self-assemble Tyrell coke culture
where for the rat model or you can see
the primary hepatocyte as kind of the
islands that are formed in the middle
and then filled in with the non
parenchymal stromal cells many of the
systems are now adding cooper cells to
create more physiologically relevant
liver environments as when at all at
merck head research the apalis it--
cooper cell model can generate crosstalk
between the cytokines and inflammatory
response for more holistic in vivo like
picture so many of these first primary
hepatocyte models may be with water
other cell type are now offering three
and four different cell types in one
nice package so essentially creating a
miniaturized tissue on a plate for those
that are familiar with primary parasites
and the liver the systems form beautiful
bile canaliculi so you can study a
variety of bile acids or look at
metabolites that can be formed in the
bile ducts
some of the early work that we did here
at Corel in comparison of our co culture
with the traditional played a tap out of
site model is to look at the RNA
expression these data were presented by
BMS and you can clearly see here the
p450s and some of the non p450s that are
expressed in the hero hepatocyte
co-culture over a period of time all the
way out to 72 hours so you can see for
example the p450s 1 a 2 3 a 4 are
relatively high and expressed and even
some of the non pipi 450s like a o and
FM o are also expressed so the culture
is acting is simply like a miniaturized
liver on a plate one of the concerns
that many companies have is as we
progress towards more difficult to
metabolize compounds companies are
having issues trying to figure out the
best way to examine the properties of
these compounds in vitro this was a
major concern for a CRO called q squared
who wanted a reliable in vitro liver
system that they could tap of their
client cons because they were being
predicted value B current pension
hepatocyte said our wanna experiment q
was two weeks to trick compounds both
low clearing and rapidly clearing in
compared to the traditional method of
primary podocytes used in suspension
plated hepatocyte on a mono layer and
the hepatocyte
in our Elko culture system you can see
here the various experimental design
that Q squared had chosen to use some of
the things from the compound selection
test set that Q squared wanted to make
sure of or that these 13 compounds were
mentally minimally arena ly cleared and
that the clearance rates could be turned
by estimation of substrate depletion
that the these intrinsic clearance
values could be scaled up here you can
see the the different compounds that
were selected as well as the main
metabolizing enzyme involved for each
one the calculations that were used to
come up with the values for these
results on the next slide and here are
the results and you can see the drugs
odd that were screened on the far left
column the next column is the literature
in vivo clearance value and then the
predicted clearance value for the
hepatocyte sand suspension hepatocyte
plated on a mono layer and inside the
hear out system and you can see for many
of the low clearing compounds like
warfarin and timolol theophylline there
was no value predicted for the apat
asides in suspension because these
compounds are so difficult to turn over
they cannot be turned over using the
traditional suspended apat asite method
for a long time the next step or Plan B
was always thought to be let's plate the
hepatocyte and this would give them
longer time longer exposure and we
should be able to predict clearance
unfortunately because once you begin to
plate nepata sites their enzymatic
function activity begins to drop off
almost immediately they were not able to
get any type of predictive value for
even some of the moderately cleared
compounds while in the URL system and
some of these more advanced systems
because they're able to maintain the
high enzymatic function that you receive
with suspended primary hepatocytes in a
plated format all the way out to 72
hours you're able to get prediction for
for compounds that are tough to
metabolize like the warfarin the timolol
theophylline and a number of others I
will say many of these advanced systems
if you look at the bottom of this slide
for some of the more rapidly turned over
compounds like the clove lac and a
phazon that these systems do have a
tendency to under predict in vivo
clearance in the in vitro environment
for many of these rapidly cleared
compounds
a similar study was performed by Astra
Zeneca were they to use the same exact
lot of primary hepatocytes in comparison
between a plaited model and the more
advanced Ural system you can see these
results published in drug metabolism
disposition in April of 2016 a group at
separate X which is another CRO located
in the UK you also did a test of the
Hurrell co-culture system and compared
it to hepatocyte syn suspension and
plated primary hepatocyte of these same
lots and they determine clearance values
or much lower than traditional Plata de
pata sites using the Hurrell system they
also found that of the 12 compounds
tested in the heroes in vitro co-culture
model they were able to get a predicted
in vivo clearance within 3 fold for
seven of those compounds so you can
clearly see that these more advanced
systems offer a very nice prediction as
to what can take place in vivo one of
the other concerns is not only clearance
but when it comes to metabolite
generation and being able to show that
you're seeing relevant metabolites being
formed particularly with the FDA's new
mist guidance and having to identify
certain metabolites that appear at
greater than 25% you need a reliable
system to ensure that you're not only
generating metabolites that you can see
in the in vitro environment but also so
you're not surprised when you go in vivo
and you see a number of metabolites in
vivo that you weren't expecting to see
or able to predict with your in vitro
system AstraZeneca did a very nice
publication with the hero system and
that's published in molecular
pharmaceutics and as a snapshot here you
can see with warfarin hepatocyte syn
suspension at 2 hours on the bottom
left-hand corner here that you're
forming very little of the m6
metabolites however in the pot aside
co-cultures you're forming a number of
metabolites that are all relevant in all
and peer in vivo
similar results with the folks at Q
squared this was an add-on to the
clearance project that I had previously
shown what key squared wanted to look at
were major metabolites and the
possibility that they can be formed
accurately in the Hurrell
system the study design was a four-hour
hepatocyte suspension incubation
compared to the Hiroko cultures all the
way out to 168 hours or 7 days with no
media changes the three compounds
selected were meloxicam timolol and xk
four six nine and as you can see on the
very top bar here with the standard of
had a site for our incubation for
meloxicam you see very little formation
of the mawashi hydroxy and almost no
their metabolites being formed with the
hero Elko culture system you're able to
generate malach C carboxylic acid malach
C hydroxy many of the in vivo relevant
metabolites that you weren't able to
predict with your standard classical
system and not only can the here all Co
culture do this but also some of the
other systems the micro pattern system
as well does a very good job at
generating metabolites you can see here
again with timolol the formation of the
timolol glue Quran I'd let a blight the
morphine bring opening the loss of the
ethyl bridge at 72 hours and you know
the formation of the in vivo relevant
metabolites the last compound that Q
squared chose to look at was XK 469 this
compound was of particular interest
because the major metabolite is formed
via a non p450 pathway in this case the
major metabolite is formed via the AO or
aldehyde oxidase pathway so they wanted
to make sure that not only were p450s
Express as I showed in the earlier slide
from BMS but also that non p450s were
expressed in the system and here you can
see that the major metabolite being
formed via the AO pathway is clearly
present in being formed Q squared
published these results just recently in
drug metabolism
addition this past August and here's
their take away and studies evaluating
the hiroko culture system observed
incubations using we're better than
observed incubations compared to
conventional hepatocytes in suspension
Eli Lilly has also done a great deal of
work in the ural system also looking at
qualitative and quantitative prediction
of human in vivo metabolites in their
pathways this published was published
this past year in xenobiotic a-- as well
so I previously mentioned one of the
biggest concerns with some of these more
advanced systems and with compounds that
are coming out that are difficult to
metabolize is it concern over are we
missing anything and is there potential
for surprises once you do get further
along and get into the clinic and you
can see here from these data where the
particular client looked at their parent
compound in s9 fractions hepatocyte
since suspension two different fresh
apat asite donors with compound exposure
all the way out to four days and the
hero human system you can clearly see
around 27 the significant loss of the
parent in the Kuril system as well as
formation of the secondary and tertiary
metabolites throughout these
spectroscopy skin so BMS did a very nice
comparison of our hero of self-assembled
co-culture and compared it to by
reclamation IV T's micro pattern system
what they found is that both of the
advanced systems performed very well at
examining many of the low turnover
compounds that they had screened one of
the advantages of the more advanced
systems is that both far out perform the
traditional plated hepatocytes as well
as the hepa RG cell lines that were
plated and exposed to compound the hero
system had worked better and predicted
better for compounds that tended to be
more acidic while the micro pattern by
reclamation ivt system works very well
for compounds that
were more basic on the spectrum so they
previously mentioned these systems have
a do a very good job at exposing the
bile canaliculi and forming bile
canaliculi for a variety of transporter
applications that science can do here
you can see the Purell pata site
co-culture about the human in rats EDF
stain and look at beautiful formation of
the bile canaliculi now many of these
bile experiments come in handy for a
number of applications one direct
comparison is to look at in in vitro bc
BDC study or bile duct cannulated study
these results here or comparison of the
hero flux bile canaliculi model in vitro
and compared it to what the group lung
quest at all did were they cannulated
directly into the bile ducts of the rats
in vivo and what we show is a comparison
within 3 fold of our in vitro system to
what they got in vivo where they
cannulated directly into the bile ducts
of the rats for both digoxin and almost
spot-on with reserve a statin now what
these bile duct studies are allow folks
to do is you can take your in vivo BTC
study data you can take your in vitro
BDC data in the rat and also now you're
able to get BTC data in human while it's
impossible to cannulate directly into
the bile ducts of living donors
scientists and researchers researchers
can take these three data points and
plug them into their more advanced
models to get a very nice prediction of
what could happen in the clinic one of
the other big advantages of these more
advanced systems is their ability to
look at a compound toxicity over time
many of the traditional hepatocytes and
cell line models only allow very
exposure to compounds before the cells
themselves become necrotic and begin to
die off what these more advanced systems
allow is for longer-term prediction with
the ability to repeat those compounds
over an extended period of time this
allows researchers to look at a number
of things like drug-induced liver injury
as well as coolio static liabilities a
number of other more mechanistic
toxicities that can come up and be
presented over time that the traditional
a standard primary hepatocyte source
online studies cannot do one of the
examples is a project that we ourselves
did with Sanofi they looked at 19 well
studied compounds plus 10 of additional
Sanofi compounds all with known Dilli
exposure these data here show
particularly for compounds like
cyclophosphamide and acetaminophen you
can see the dosing over time with the
various endpoints all of these data here
are ATP and you can see for
cyclophosphamide for example at the
24-hour time point there's very little
toxicity but as you go out further with
exposure over time the compound becomes
more and more toxic as as picked up in
the URL system similar results for rats
and similar results for dog and you can
see in the dog particular that the
seven-day and 14-day results are almost
the same so the compound shows much more
toxic exposure at day 7 compared to some
of the others similar results for
acetaminophen one of the take homes that
Sanofi found was their traditional
method of looking at human apat asite in
a monoculture measuring the TC 50s over
c max at 24 hours with their traditional
method for the test set of compounds
they were able to get a prediction of
correctly predict 6 of the 12 toxic
compounds
and 7 of the 7 non toxic compounds what
we found is for exposure
all the way out to 14 days we were able
to pick up an additional four compounds
as toxic so ten of the twelve compounds
that registered some type of toxic
response again with no false picking up
all through negative lis toxic compounds
similar results were seen in the rat
though it wasn't as pronounced to pick
up so know if he was able to get nine of
the twelve predicted correctly for the
toxic compounds where the hero system
picked up ten of the twelve and similar
results for dog whether jor-el system
picked up eleven of the twelve the other
thing these more advanced systems can do
is their work very well for third party
analytical systems so for high content
analysis the micro pattern system works
very well because you can screen in on
the little hepatic islands that are
formed it also works very well in a
number of time based impedance readouts
a company called ASEA that has a
real-time cell analysis machine where
you can look at toxicity over time and
these more advanced systems give very
accurate predictions of what is
occurring with your compounds on in
vitro other benefits of the more
advanced systems are the ability to use
these systems as a viral vector in other
words being able to administer virus
whether it's hepatitis B malaria
hepatitis C and other viruses to these
primary hepatic co-culture models to use
them as a mechanism to screen
therapeutic compounds in development you
can see here that the primary hepatocyte
co-culture model with Jarell offers much
greater infective rate compared to the
traditional Hep g2s
that are with NTC P as well as some of
the other primary cell types and you can
see the
models are is the very high bar for at
both days 7 14 and 21 post-infection so
not only are you able to infect the
system more easily but it's able to
maintain that those high levels of
infection for extended periods of time
now many researchers that have worked
with viruses such as HPV particularly
with primary hepatocytes know that there
are a variety of donor to donor
differences with the as it pertains to
the ability to infect the cells with a
virus one of the unique things about
some of these more advanced systems is
their ability to work with a variety of
different donors well you will see some
donor to do our differences as
referenced in plot B here as the
exposure with the virus over time you
can see that all five of the donors are
clearly above the negative reference
control and this worked for all of the
donors that were tested in the more
advanced system that virus it was able
to be infected yes it at different
levels but the donor to donor
differences were minimalized that every
donor tested did have the ability and
show the ability to be infected one of
the really fascinating things with these
more advanced systems is the ability to
only be infected with virus but be
infected with the virus coming from
patient-derived HBV this is very unique
in that this this serum samples were
taken and exposed to the cells and the
cells were actually able to pick up some
of the the virus from the various
patients and here you can see the
results for a number of different
samples that were tested six different
samples were tested in all six different
samples showed infection with the
patient derives here
these more advanced systems not only
work well for HPV but also for malaria
here you can see the formation of
sporozoites inside the cell in
comparison with the hero system compared
to monocultures of primary hepatocytes
as we move to the future these tissue
systems are becoming more and more
advanced essentially creating miniature
organs on a plate or chip as the common
lingo is referred to in industry now
there are a number of different organ on
chip systems that are currently some
commercially available and some still
under development what I'm going to
touch on is our system that is still
currently under in development but on
its way and in should be to the market
very soon what our system is comprised
of is a housing with a plate that looks
a chip that essentially looks like a
microscope slide with each one having an
individual set up as an individual
experiment you can see on the top
picture on the right-hand side the
little red caps are the reservoirs
inside the black ring those are each
different experimental chambers inside
of that is a to tissue compartment where
you can have liver cells for example or
some other type of gut cells or cardiac
cells or some other cell type to look at
interactive studies here is a blow-up of
the system itself the white plastic
pieces on top are clips that hold on the
binders what are fascinating with these
organ on ships and micro fluidic systems
is their ability to predict what happens
in vivo these are some early results
where we looked at mono static primary
hepatocytes plated mono static kepada
sites under flow conditions our Purell
static system and the hero flow system
and on the y-axis you can see in vivo
measured clearance and on the x-axis is
the scaled in vitro clearance and
looking at the correlation between each
one you can see with the mono static by
itself predicted the least within our
squared value of 0.62 while the hero
system both the more advanced tissue
model system under microfluidic
conditions had a very nice r-squared
correlation not only does the system
work very well for predicting clearance
but also works very well for looking at
metabolite generation you can see the
results for dextro fan and see
diminution formation of metabolites in
the various systems whether it be the
hero flow model the static model or the
just mono static model of primary
hepatocyte as I previously mentioned one
of the unique things about these dual
chamber and multi-chambered applications
is the ability to look at other tissue
types in particular here the liver heart
kidney lungs having a liver and a
disease model as well as some other type
of targeted therapeutic inside each
these of these dual chambered systems
would be comprised of a liver component
as well as the target tissue components
one of the early experiments that we did
with our system was to look at Tiger fur
which is a pro drug that gets converted
to 5-fluorouracil
after it goes metabolism in the liver
that the act of metabolites is actually
the drug that would kill off any of the
cancer cells here you can see the
results with the plus liver component as
well as the - liver components in the
top is the liver component and then in
the bottom is a colorectal cancer cell
and you can see results with plus liver
the blue is the control the five is the
cytotoxicity that was caused by the tegu
fir and the yellow is the cytotoxicity
that was comprised just by 5fu itself
you can see with the plus liver that the
taiga fur and 5-fu results are almost
identical in that it killed off nearly
80% of the colorectal cancer cells in
the secondary chamber without the liver
components you can see that the tiger
fur was not converted to the 5-fu and
the red block is very low where only two
or three percent of the cells had died
off mostly probably because of their own
in the condition however with the 5fu by
itself you can see that worked very well
again killing off nearly 80 percent of
the cells as we look to the future one
of the ideas is being able to take these
orang on a chip systems and make them
amenable to a more high-throughput
application one of the thoughts is to
have up to 20 or 30 different individual
experiments on one single plate each one
with its own reservoir as well as the
two chambered system that can all be
analyzed in a its own analyzed housing
so to conclude there are a number of
advantages and also concerns as we move
towards these more advanced systems some
of the advantages includes the superior
functionality that you get with these
more advanced systems compared to the
classical research methods that are out
there the improvements in prediction to
be able to predict what can happen in
vivo on your desktop is certainly very
fascinating the potential in vitro
platforms that can be used for studies
of infectious diseases in various
disease state models since they seem to
readily take up many of the deliver
diseases that weren't taken up very well
with the
primary hepatocyte spy themselves also
is these more advanced systems used
comprised of human tissue can also help
replace and minimize the animal testing
that is being done I know in the EU
particular many of these systems have
really taken off to minimize that the
use of testing on animals some of the
concerns with these words ant system
certainly is the organ to organ
interplay or essentially as our bodies
we have our own blood which works very
well with all of our various organs and
tissues however when you take these
systems outside of the body it becomes
very difficult to find a media that
works best for each one of the
individualized tissues particularly with
some of the more advanced six seven and
eight tissue types on a a culture plate
it becomes extremely difficult to find a
media that works very well for every
single type of tissue also some of the
regulatory hurdles that many of the
agencies are still relying on the
classical methods because it just hasn't
been enough experimentation done with
some of these more advanced systems
though I think many of the regulatory
agencies are open to change as the
improvements are made in these systems
and as they be can continue to become
more popular throughout industry also
some of these platforms can be rather
cumbersome and not necessarily ideal to
work with also the the difficulty with
commercialization many of these
platforms I would say are somewhat
rudimentary and a little academic in
that as monies become available and
these companies begin to develop emulate
in particular has done a fantastic job
of raising money and creating a buzz
around their platform and you know it's
really about rising tide lifts all ships
and we're seeing that across the board
with a number of these more advanced
systems and with that I would like to
conclude and
thank the folks at lab route very well
very much and thank you I hope you found
this informative and I really enjoyed
presenting on some of the more advanced
liver tissue model systems that are
currently available on the market thank
you
Thank You mr. Shipton for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any of your questions
you've submitted via email that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon goodbye